BUT THEY’RE GOING TO TRY TO
CLAIM CREDIT FOR THE USMCA,
WHICH WAS ALL TRUMP.
JOINING US NOW, KEVIN McCARTHY,
OF COURSE THE HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER.
HE WILL JOIN US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN McCARTHY, I DON’T
THINK RETAKING THE HOUSE IS A
PIPE DREAM ANYMORE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
>> IT’S NOT.
DO YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE FEWER
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE SINCE
NANCY PELOSI HELD THE GAVEL?
AT THAT MOMENT WE NEEDED 19
SEATS TO WIN THE MAJORITY.
TODAY WE NEED 17.
WE WON EVERY SPECIAL ELECTION WE
PLAYED IN, AND THAT WAS IN
DEMOCRAT SEATS.
THE DEMOCRATS WON BY NINE POINTS
AND HAPPENED TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE REAL QUESTION IS, WHAT ARE
THE RESULTS OF THE DEMOCRATS?
THEY SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED HOW
MUCH THEY HAVE EMBRACED THE
SOCIALISTS.
NAME ME ONE PROBLEM THIS
DEMOCRAT MAJORITY HAS SOLVED?
THERE ISN’T ONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE DONE?
WE ROLLED OUT A COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO
COMMITMENTTOAMERICA.COM AND YOU
CAN SEE FOR YOURSELF.
WE’RE GOING TO REBUILD THE
BIGGEST ECONOMY WE HAVE EVER
SEEN.
ADDED 10 MILLION NEW JOBS.
GOING TO RESTORE OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE’RE GOING TO DO?
WE’RE GOING TO END COVID.
WE’RE GOING TO CREATE A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE VACCINE.
WE PROTECT PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE DON’T DEFUND THE COPS.
WE ADD 1.75 BILLION.
TO MAKE MORE POLICE TRAINING.
COMMUNITY POLICING AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, 500,000 BODY
CAMERAS.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, LET ME
JUMP IN HERE.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU HAD A
SUBSTANTIVE IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION WITH NANCY PELOSI
ABOUT ANYTHING?
>> YOU KNOW, I’M AROUND HER MANY
TIMES AND MANY MEETINGS BUT I
CAN’T SAY I HAVE A SUBSTANTIVE
TALK WITH HER IN MORE THAN A
YEAR.
THINK FOR A MOMENT, YESTERDAY WE
WATCHED WORLD PEACE HAPPEN FOR
THE MIDDLE EAST ON THE STEPS
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI DID?
SHE TURNED DOWN THE INVITATION
AND HELD VOTES IN THE FLOOR OF
THE HOUSE TRYING TO MAKE MEMBERS
NOT GO THERE AND WITNESS BAHRAIN
AND THE UAE, REPRESENT AND
ACKNOWLEDGE ISRAEL.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT
YOUR REACTION.
BREAKING NEWS JUST REPORTED BY
POLITCO.
FOX NEWS CONFIRMED IT.
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS IS PRESSING
YOU TO LAUNCH LONG SHOT BID TO
OUST HERE, A PROCEDURAL GAMBET.
HAS NO CHANCE OF SUCCESS BUT
COULD FORCE VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS
TO ALIGN WITH THE SPEAKER AHEAD
OF THE ELECTION.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF IT?
>> I’M IN FAVOR OF DEFEATING
NANCY PELOSI AND JERRY NADLER
AND OTHERS.
THE REAL CHALLENGE WOULD BE
WE’RE FOUR WEEKS AWAY FROM
ELECTION.
THESE DEMOCRATS COULD VOTE
AGAINST NANCY PELOSI, USE IT IN
THEIR CAMPAIGNS TO SAY THEY’RE
NOT WITH HER EVEN THOUGH THEY
VOTE WITH HER 95% OF THE TIME.
SHE DOESN’T --
>> Laura: SO YOU’RE NOT GOING TO
DO IT?
ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT OR NOT?
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S THE BEST
MOVE AT THIS MOMENT.
THE BEST MOVE IS WHEN 218 SEATS
AND THAT DEFEATS NANCY PELOSI.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IT DEFEATS?
NADLER, MAXINE WATERS, ADAM
SCHIFF AND THE OTHERS THAT IS
THE BEST PLAY RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: DO YOU AGREE WITH ME
THERE’S TWO THINGS AT PLAY, ONE,
WHICH ALL OF YOU DO, YOU NEED TO
RAISE MONEY.
TWO, WHEN YOU’RE A DEMOCRAT AND
YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE A MODERATE,
YOU JUST PETRIFIED OF GETTING
PRIMARIED BY THE AOC PLUS THREE.
SO YOU ARE CAUGHT BETWEEN
RAISING MONEY FROM THE
ESTABLISHMENT, PELOSI AND NOT
GETTING PRIMARIED, SO YOU
BASICALLY SHUT UP.
>> YEAH, YOU WATCHED AOC PRIMARY
AND BEAT PEOPLE THIS YEAR.
THEY’RE ALL AFRAID.
AOC IS THE ONE THAT GOT PELOSI
TO IMPEACH -- DO IMPEACHMENT.
SHE WENT OUT STARTING PRIMARYING
PEOPLE FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
THERE WAS NO BASIS FOR IT.
THAT’S WHAT THEY WASTED THEIR
MAJORITY ON.
LOOK AT THE DEMOCRAT MAJORITY,
WHAT HAVE THEY STOOD FOR?
DEFUNDING THE POLICE,
DISMANTLING OF THIS NATION
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO WITH
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: OPEN BORDERS.
>> OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES ON THE
VERY FIRST DAY REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THIS ECONOMY IS AT.
THEY HAVE NOT BUILT NEW JOBS,
THEY HAVE NOT LOWERED THE DRUG
PRICE.
IF YOU RENEW THE NATION, RESTORE
OUR WAY OF LIFE.